the Saints could have been in play for a
starting quarterback but Drew Brees
under contract for reportedly two years
50 million but it's got to be a dummy
second year it's a one-year deal we got
to see what the cash flow is for this
year they have that 21 million in cap
space they have to deal with my guess is
he got a gigantic signing bonus and they
spread that over two years to deal with
that cap number he's still going to have
a big cap number for 2020 but he's the
guy and Taysom Hill will presumably be
there as well and it's going to be
interesting Chris to see how they divide
the labor in 2020 between Brees and Hill
as they get ready for 2021 when
presumably Brees retires and Hill takes
over yeah that's right I mean it is not
unexpected any of this right we knew
this was gonna happen Brees you know I'm
sure was patient here and the fact that
I'm sure the Saints and Sean Payton and
everybody you know have been talking to
Teddy Bridgewater you know they were
still trying to figure out the taste of
Hill situation they got all that figured
out but to me Mike here's the thing that
jumps out to me you know okay we know
taste in Hills the future but if they
still want to use Taysom Hill in a
creative way and use them like we've
seen the last two years and expand that
they need to sign even another
quarterback you know they got to have
this year's version of Teddy Bridgewater
so in case the Brees does get hurt or
banged up you know that they can either
make Taysom Hill to back up and have
somebody be insurance to him or you know
have the backdoor played and taste some
Hill splits duty and they use him
creatively - so they're still in a
little predicament here to me to where
they're gonna have to get another
quarterback down there to be a little
bit of a fail-safe plan for Taysom Hill
if they want to still use them as this
jack-of-all-trades player because hey
when you're playing fullback and tight
end and you're running the ball at
quarterback there's a chance you could
get banged up and what if he gets banged
up and then the next week drew Brees
let's just say sprains as I thought he
can't play what the hell does the Saints
do so I think they're gonna have to have
a back-up plan for their back to a plan
here in New Orleans but the the Brees
news not not necessarily shocking well
in the speculation I saw that makes a
lot of sense
find a way to bring chase Daniel back to
New Orleans if you need that veteran who
can step in and and backup Drew Brees so
Taysom Hill can keep being taste some
Hill because you have to have a separate
offense when Hill takes over and that
presumably will be in 2021
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports